Oh
you
all right hi everyone Jeff clima here
for new media rockstars I happen to be
sitting here with John Boswell correct
yes all right good I just want to make
sure as you know some it wasn't some
French pronunciation something like that
okay good now most people know him
better I believe as melody sheep and so
John how are you doing today how are you
I am I'm excellent don't worry about me
I'm not that interesting so let's get it
will kind of softball and do it a little
bit here what is your favorite episode
of Family Guy oh man maybe not such a
softball question to start with everyone
else thinks I'm pretty sure okay and
that that's what I mean that's well
obviously why I'm asking you melody
sheep as yet because that whole is that
is that where you derived the name or
did it come out of some other thing and
oh that's where I came from I was just
watching that episode and you know just
kind of stuck with me as a really funny
name I might have been looking for a
username at that point you know all my
life for some reason or another and I
just kind of attached to it and okay so
I mean it doesn't really come in as I
think there's no there's no aspect of
say science or anything that ties into
it correct no no you know but it is kind
of a a name that's unique enough to kind
of associated with a brand or something
so I kind of ran with it after that you
know instead of just being someone
random username you know it's memorable
enough that you know people will recall
it and use it as kind of brand name you
know yeah okay well no now your gig is
kind of been so far has been basically
like that not not even to say basically
that makes it sound derivative but you
auto-tune science basically and so why
science well you know I wasn't really
interested in it in high school it was
just kind of something that was a little
bit boring to me but I went to college
and I just kind of discovered this whole
new world of you know crazy concepts and
astronomy and biology and it was mostly
Geor classes that I definitely need to
take but there's just seemed the most
interesting to me and I took that my
mind was blown you know this is some
crazy stuff that you're the they never
teach you in high school or that you're
not really exposed to as a kid or maybe
that you just don't understand as a kid
you know it's really cool concepts and
and then at the same time I saw Carl
Sagan's Cosmos for the first time I was
a sophomore and that also blew me away I
mean just the retro awesomeness of Carl
Sagan and the whole PBS special in
general was just amazing to me and I
really you know for years I would watch
him over and over again and I didn't
really appeal to me didn't the thought
didn't come to me to actually auto-tune
it until the Gregory Brothers showed up
in 2009 they they really paved the way
for using autotune in a tree makes sense
but you've never been done before
and I said well you know I love Carl
Sagan is one of my biggest fascinations
and why not try to infect on him and it
works so well I mean people loved it
from the get-go which is great and it
was a good match you know so now Carl
Sagan is is one of your ears say your
inspirations scientifically like who are
some of the other sign inspirations in
that world both both let's say
scientifically and musically uh you know
I was into a fixed wing and kind of the
IDM scene for a long time you can kind
of hear that my music a lot but I I
wasn't a metal band in high school so I
you know kind of tasted all over the
place and and I was also an EP at the
time you know which is kind of my scene
now but other scientists you know
richard fineman was huge to me he's just
another really cool figure you know
really childlike and really interesting
yeah equal to Carl Sagan in my eyes now
but I wasn't really as familiar with him
back then okay now you mentioned that
year you're kind of in into the indie
scene a little bit here as well you have
a couple of side projects right there's
what Hudson and
color pulse yeah you know one of my
problems as a artist is I make music
under too many different names you know
you get melody sheep symphony of science
list goes on Hudson I just released a
kind of an indie rock folk rock album
about science called Terra Lumina which
is another name to have to remember if
you're a fan of mine but I just it's
it's fun to kind of make music under
these different monitors because there's
no expectations already attached to the
name that you're working under and so
you can kind of be a little bit more
free in the way work and that kind of
thing just just long now speaking of
Terra Lumina since you brought it up
here you actually did that as a
Kickstarter project correct yeah we did
now yeah how did they come about it well
we wanted the really interested in
Kickstarter for awhile and I wanted to
kind of make a bigger album that I'm
used to making you know actually get
some real resources attached and and do
it right and was something I really
wanted to do was original science music
instead of sampling things you know
which is which is a lot of fun but it's
all different beast and so we raised a
lot of money on Kickstarter over the
summer and you know we spent six five
six months working on this thing and
finally got it out and it's been great
you know great reviews and it was a
really interesting process to have funds
attached you know hiring musicians and
I'm getting it mixed and mastered and
produced better and just a lot of fun
okay because you set out to raise like
what I think 10,000 and you ended up
getting like 23,000 and change something
like that out for over two hours and
which is amazing you know totally
unexpected but great news yeah those are
good hit for you now it does I mean so
when you get an extra influx of money
like that does it I mean does it just go
towards better musicians and better
better sound studio time or I mean what
is the extra money disappear into or how
does that get funneled and use yeah like
you said better musicians you know more
time spent in the studio and tweaking
things and we spent a lot of time in the
artwork too that was something we were
prepared to funnel too many resources
towards originally but then you know
we've got all this extra money that we
kind of were searching for and then we
spent a lot of that on getting an
armored ride and making the whole
package just work really well together
and if you order the CD it's it's pretty
cool it's a we work with a couple
different artists on a bunch of stuff
and they work out really well now in
kind of researching the Kickstarter
thing for you I I noticed that for your
$200 backers kind of the reward let's
say was that they got to Skype with you
so I kind of feel like I owe you 200
dollars now it's not an awkward
situation
oh I mean that's uh it's something that
we want to connect with the fans you
know more directly than just thank you
here's the product you know I hope you
like the music so it's just it's a Skype
and then we can you know continue to
talk they have ideas for our future
music or the highest backers actually
got a song you know we get to make him a
song which has been fun we haven't
really done well yet but okay that's
really interesting to to work with
people and kind of their own idea of the
song and seeing what they like to do and
you know that's awesome
yeah I kind of noticed that this year
yeah your thousand dollar backers and I
think there were like five of them did
you have to get any weird requested they
want you this thing about anything kind
of offbeat or awkward ah you know it's
we're just in the early phases we've
only done one complete song and we're
kind of working with the rest of them on
how to do the rest and it's really
interesting to kind of get that you know
influence from totally random places you
would never expect to but it's kind of
it makes you push the envelope on your
own work a little bit and kind of force
yourself to be creative with ideas that
we came from totally random places
Thanks now you had a you had a song /
video auto-tune that was it was let us
all unite
I think which ran into kind of a
copyright infringement snag like what
happened there
you know it's happened to me I think
three times this year which is too bad
the family saw the video on Huffington
Post I think and they you know they
weren't happy with it we talked to them
I tried you you know I try to argue that
people are loving this and it's good for
the original you know it can only help
the original content you know as a
promotional tool but I mean ultimately
they decided that it wasn't in the
spirit of the original because I
manipulated it enough and they decided
to take it down you know I mean if
there's still a chance maybe it'll come
up later again you know we're still
trying to talk about it I mean you do
have to respect the copyright owners
requests when they tell you to do
whatever you want they want something
it's hard but it's something gotta do
now you did it also kind of a badass
Shark Week mashup did any copyright
issues there have they've been pretty
cool about it any word actually no that
one was done with the blessing of the
Discovery Channel so they were kind of
saying hey they'll be fine if you did
this here's some resources you can use
and that's the best of both worlds and
someone there's something you want to do
in the owner job board with that which
was a really nice collaboration you know
it worked out pretty well and okay so as
far as channels go like you've also done
some stuff with like PBS yeah yeah that
was a big one over the summer it is
still going actually they got in touch
with me back in January 12 months ago
and they said you know we want to do mr.
Rogers remix and about Ross one and I
was I was thrilled you know that's just
amazing because I was actually already
kind of playing around with the Bob Ross
remix before they even got in touch so
yeah I was fully on board with that and
the Mister Rogers one was the first one
to come out and that was probably the
biggest one I think it was tons of fun
to do and we were actually going to to
do a series of Mister Rogers before any
of the other ones but we decided based
on the popularity that we should just
focus on you know one person at a time
figure it as I move on I'm not sure if
we'll ever revisit Mister Rogers again
but you know there was there's tons of
material to use so I mean if there's
ever more chances to work with him there
I'm sure or something very will come of
that
now you also do I think I saw that you
you got to attend the TED conference is
that right yeah I did they invited me
back you know it was probably year a
half ago this has come in 2012 10 and I
was like oh how they are that's that's
amazing and they flew me down there it
was kind of crazy you know it's there's
like 40 hours of talks during the week
and I was there I went to everyone and I
took notes with a little stopwatch
saying okay 30 minutes into this guy's
talk there's cook there's a cool quote
there I could use and then at night you
know yeah I want to miss a bunch of the
socialization events and all that stuff
just because I had to run back to my
little hotel room in in my little studio
portable studio set up and kind of work
on this remix like so late in the night
and in looking up pretty well I mean I
think they liked it and it was really
fun to do you've had a pretty a pretty
awesome 2012 I have to say what was
awesome yes now you also got to you also
got to collaborate with Jack White yeah
that was actually had a couple years ago
that was when a glorious dawn the first
Carlson remix came out and he got in
touch with me you know pretty shortly
after it came out as it look I really
like this thing I have a vision of
putting this out on vinyl on a 45
minutes or 45 I was like wow I almost
didn't believe it at first you know this
is kind of disbelief but his his team
took care of all the legal stuff and got
in touch with Karl's Widow and you know
did all of them the right stuff and made
it super easy for me and it was a breeze
and came out it was beautiful of
university nice he's kind of a science
minded guy as well I guess he's really
do like the Tesla coil and stuff did you
guys get to shoot the science breeze not
too much really but I heard he
the planetary society now or something
like that yeah
alright now I mean obviously auto-tune
can't or maybe can can go on forever
like where do you see yourself going
musically you know I I'm kind of uh
mostly I see an electronic producer but
you know I like to do the indie stuff
you know will tear alumina and Hudson
and you can find that stuff on my
channel too I'm trying to branch off
into you know kind of soundtracks and
you know sound design you know I made a
video called our story in one minute
this year that kind of boiled down a
bunch of really cool footage from 20 or
30 documentaries into a tapestry of to
tell us a story of humans from Big Bang
to present day and I had a lot of fun
with that you know kind of doing an
orchestral almost mixing with electronic
sound soundtrack to that song to that
video and that's kind of the thing I
want to branch into as I go on because
you're right I mean auto-tune isn't
going to be around forever or just kind
of kind of die off isn't gonna be a fad
but I think my skills are equally
applicable to the kind of soundtrack
scene and kind of the video editing
skills I have in mesh with that so
that's the direction I'm trying to go
next
well cool well John I appreciate you
taking the time to sit down with new
media rockstars and I wish you all the
best and I look forward to seeing what
you do next
thank you happy holidays hey you as well
I'll talk to you soon all right man
goodbye
you